Welcome to Applied Cryptography.
Cryptography is a branch of mathematics
and computer science--that's a lot of fun--it's about
using secrets to solve problems.
In this class we're going to learn about
some of the foundations of cryptography
and we're also going to learn to use cryptography
to solve problems in computing,
like how to send messages securely,
how to manage accounts on websites,
and how to do things like perform computation
where you can keep your data secret
and still get the result of a function
that depends on your data and some other data.
The name cryptography has two parts:
crypto comes from the Greek root for secret--to hide--
and cryptography's all about using secrets.
The second part comes from the root meaning writing--
this is the same graphy that appears in telegraphy or photography.
What we do in this course, and what we do in cryptography
involves a lot more than just secret writing.
It's really everything to do with secrets.
So a better name for the course would be cryptology.
Cryptography is used so frequently in practice, though,
that it makes more sense to use the name cryptography,
even though our concern is with the much larger goal
of understanding how to use secrets in general.
And cryptology is the science of secrets
which is really what this course is all about.
So that's enough to answer the first quiz,
and the first quiz will check
that you understand the definition of cryptology.
So the question is, which of these involve cryptology?
Check all of the answers that do.
Opening a door--and I mean a traditional door,
using a traditional key.
Playing a game of poker.
Logging into your account at Udacity,
or doing a search using google.com,
and I should be a little more specific for this last one,
this assumes you're doing the search today,
and you're already logged in to one of your Google accounts.